but we begin with a pretty stunning
development in the civil court trial of
right-wing conspiracy theorist alex
jones who's being sued for spreading
lies about the 2012 sandy hook massacre
it happened as he testified on his own
behalf a lawyer for the victim's parents
revealed he now holds years of jones
private text messages that were
accidentally leaked by jones attorneys
the lawyer says they show jones lied
about a number of things including how
much money he's made from all of this
nancy chen is here with an update an
update on this case nancy good morning
david good morning to you the parents of
a six-year-old victim are seeking 150
million dollars in damages but yesterday
in court they got something else they
have wanted for years alex jones finally
admitted under oath he knows the sandy
hook massacre really happened
it's 100 percent real i think sandy hook
happened
and i think it's a terrible event that
reversal from alex jones was just the
first in a series of surprising
revelations on the last day of testimony
in a remarkable exchange lawyers for the
family said they had years worth of text
messages from jones mr jones
did you know that 12 days ago
12 days ago
your attorneys messed up and sent me an
entire digital copy of your entire cell
phone with every text message you've
sent for the past two years the lawyer
said the messages show jones withheld
evidence in the defamation lawsuits
about the sandy hook shooting mr dunce
in discovery you were asked do you have
standing hook text messages on your
phone and you said no correct
you said that under oath sometimes
didn't you everybody was mistaken i was
mistaken but you got into the messages
right there you know
so alex jones has a lot more to worry
about now than just a lawsuit alexander
tobbs is a civil rights attorney
following the case
he has to worry about whether he might
get arrested for perjury for obstruction
of justice or for any other criminal
activity that's found on those phones
last friday infowars parent company
filed for bankruptcy protection and over
the course of the trial jones has
repeatedly claimed his company is
bankrupt you may not tell this jury that
you are bankrupt that is also not true
on wednesday lawyers brought up jones
financials in court asserting at one
point he made up to 800 thousand dollars
a day from ads it goes to motive alex
jones exploited the heinous tragedy of
sandy hook for his own personal gait and
he was saying things that were so
outrageous and so unbelievable that it
was attracting a lot of viewers to his
content and he capitalized on that
now even though the messages were sent
by mistake they can't be used in court
because jones lawyers failed to take
back the evidence within 10 days as
texas law allows a lawyer for the
parents also told us the january 6 house
committee has contacted him about jones
messages signaling the committee may be
looking to use his conversations for its
investigation now i know the 150 million
dollars seems like a lot but the money
can't heal the pain that these families
have been through and what they will
continue to go through
but it does
help stop the perpetuation of him
spreading these lies once he says okay i
admit that this really happened and to
that point apparently one of his
attorneys said yesterday he's prepared
to pay
a dollar
for each of these defamation claims any
chance that he could win an appeal as a
result of the lawyer mishandling that
information i think this is something
we're gonna have to see play out after
the verdict comes in and there's also
the point of just what it means to have
everything on the record like this too
after
years of the spread of what his spread
is you know there's so many people who
do listen to what he has to say there's
power in the tongue that's for sure
nancy thank you